I want to get to this issue because I
heard you I heard you just say something
about their stupid and I heard you say
the word idiot you talk about what we're
just talking about Republicans yes okay
good okay stupid yeah you did I heard it
you said the word stupid and I'm
bringing this up because this guy
Jonathan Gruber
he's an MIT professor who worked on the
Obama healthier moaning okay okay wait
big controversy because they've found a
tape of him basically saying the
American people are stupid because he
was say a lot of tapes because what he
was saying was to get the bill passed we
had to do a lot of sleight of hand or
else they never would have voted for it
if we called it a tax even though it was
it tax you have to like basically slip a
pill in the dog's food I mean that in a
piece of ham to get the dog to eat the
bill yeah I agree
and I've heard nobody else in America
say that everybody on the left and the
right oh how could he call Americans
stupid show the clip of the one man in
America who agrees with him but I would
never put anything past this stupid
country because people are dummies they
don't know what's going on I think a lot
of them are just dumb I'm the bad guy
for saying people are dumb they're not
bright enough to really understand the
issues people are already complaining
that you're calling the United States a
stupid country and giving you a chance
to clarify I don't need to clarify it is
your soul mates okay how this is even
controversial I have no idea it's pretty
fun
literally way you were playing that I
thought I thought back to a debate I had
with John Avlon on CNN and I said voters
were stuck on stupid he rolling we can't
call the American people stupid I said
yeah we can call a lot of them stupid
when you look at the actual studies how
many Americans can name all 50 states in
terms of cities we need on the whole
line we have some fundamental issues we
want to play nice when it's also just
about being honest only to people who've
checked out of our price only 42 percent
can name the three branches of
government
35% can't name any branches of
government if you just want to stick
with Obamacare you ask people do you
like Obama hate Obamacare then yes if
you like what's in it we love that no or
do you like the Affordable Care Act
absolutely but Obamacare hate it it's
also same thing 45% say the economy is
the most important issue you know what
the average American thinks the
unemployment rate is thirty two percent
it's five point eight even the Great
Depression it was twenty five you ever
asked what foreign aid is foreign aid
they think that's right most most money
they think mericans what they think we
spend the most money on 33 percent spend
say foreign aid you couldn't find it in
the budget with the jeweler's up sixty
percent believe the Noah's Ark story is
literally drew how everybody in the
media can defend the American how dare
you say they're stupid was a movie on
that must be true what woke Noah's Ark
Noah's Ark I could make dumb and dumber
I thought you meant that I'm the only
non-american here but I'm gonna defend
American or Canadian smarter Canadians
are very smart especially the people who
live in my district those are the
smartest Canadians Toronto Centre I love
you oh that's a that's a suck-up right
there yeah way to go you're getting
different
I'm defending Americans here that is
pronounce about know about know about
your immense not really but the fact
that Americans have checked out of
politics or that Americans find the
health care reforms to be really
confusing I don't think you can blame
regular American people for that I think
you have to blame the media and
politicians can you blame them for not
knowing the three branches of government
for checking out on that one cuz that
one happened a lot before health care
came down the pike but we're talking
about health care talk about them
they're stupid Gruber was right Gruber
just uber was right he just said what
people don't want to he said that we're
gonna take the money from the people can
afford insurance who are healthy and
young and don't have expensive illnesses
and give it to people are sick and older
everybody knew that and also Aris wasn't
gonna come from we live in a democracy
louie gohmert Michelle Bachman these
people didn't get there by a coup
somebody elected these morons because
they represent them all right